demander de l'aide quand on en a besoin
peut parfois s'avérer un processus
exténuant vraiment le pouvoir lorsque la
pandémie a frappé l'hiver dernier andré
deschâtelets était déjà en rémission de
cancer il gagnait sa vie en vendant des
voitures usagées et puis en mars
son chiffre d'affaires a baissé de façon
brutale mais vu que les revenus à
claques aux bulbes et finalement tout
d'abord vu plus de revues bon je vais
droit le plus eu au téléphone l' agence
du revenu lui indique qu'il est
admissible à la prestation d'urgence
comme son revenu brut était supérieure à
5000 dollars en 2019
mais quelques mois plus tard lagence
leurs contacts avec un message différent
j'ai reçu une lettre du grand moment
bâle a besoin vous n'êtes plus jeunes
nous croyons que vous ne pas nous
croyons que vous n'êtes pas du jeu les
employés de l'agencé avait mal renseigné
au départ c'est le revenu net qui
comptait y andré allaient peut-être
devoir rembourser toute la pcu qu'il
avait reçu donc pas beaucoup je suis ce
gros nerf on a tout bébé le payer leur
je me dis peut-être en eaux profondes et
le ppe mais bon coup à moins se poser en
point de presse justin trudeau a indiqué
que les quatre cent quarante mille
travailleurs qui ont été induits en
erreur par l' agence ne serait
finalement pas pénaliser les gens qui
ont présenté une demande en fonction de
leurs revenus bruts
plutôt que de leur revenu net n'auront
pas à retourner les paiements qui leur
ont été versées mais ça c'est vraiment
une bonne nouvelle parce que ça va
peut-être diminuer un peu le niveau
détresse que plusieurs travailleurs
autonomes avec autre bonne nouvelle les
canadiens qui ont touché la pcu et qui
ont un revenu inférieur à 75 mille
dollars auront jusqu'en 2022 pour payer
leurs impôts sans intérêt que vous
puissiez vous remettre sur pied sans que
vous voyez à vous soucier de l'impôt à
payer
mais pour andré les annonces du
gouvernement trudeau ne marque pas la
fin de son casse-tête financier
je n'ai pas de revenus de plus leur en
janvier aucun revenu
le prochain une chance de ma femme
travaille
l' agence du revenu entamé un processus
normal de vérification auprès de
centaines de travailleurs autonomes
comme lui et pendant ce temps leurs
prestations d'urgence sont suspendus il
s'impose en double dames 1 tu as des
malades départ ils sont dangereux ici
laurence martin radio canada ottawa